this is the Dean the Dean jus bismillah
al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be
unto you and we're continuing this week
on the Dean show with abdullah hub came
quick his story on how he came to islam
former Christian who investigated all
the different world religions and he
came to know that this way of life was
indeed not a system organized by man but
organized by the one God the God of
Jesus Abraham Moses and the last and
final message said to mankind a problem
Hamid peace be upon him and he's here
again to share his experiences and his
story here on the D show don't go
nowhere
hey this is the theme the biju this is
the things is the thing
this is the video this is the days of
the theme jus this is the thing
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam peace be
with you isn't this a greeting of all
the messengers that's right all the
messages they didn't use what they
didn't just greet each other like hey
what's up how you doing they did this
greeting that us Muslims are doing isn't
it that's right yeah they say they
started their affairs and peace in peace
were people of peace that's right one
more but it seems like there's a lot of
misconceptions we're going to we're
going to maybe pick your brain on that
too but can you please people can go to
the Dean show calm for those that missed
last week's show they can go there to
view it now can you kind of bring people
up to speed and kind of summarize where
we left off and to where we are starting
today smilla rahmanir rahim I was raised
in the United States and Boston and you
know I to a very religious family
hard-working family and so I had good
values from the beginning and I was
fortunate to be in the company of
students from major universities
although we lived in a housing project
we were in between two major
universities so I had access to
information so i was learning street
life and how to be tough and rough but
at the same time i was learning
information about the world so that
really was an opening for me and that
that enabled me to question some of the
wrong practices within you know that i
found within the church to leave the
church and to begin to look at world
religions i went to university in
pennsylvania and an oregon i was upset
you know with this system it was the 60s
and we were questioning everything
around us so i left the university and i
was drafted and in order to avoid this
confusion I became a war resister and I
migrated to Canada
and it was in Toronto Canada all praises
due to allah that I accepted Islam at
the hands of a great scholar dr. Hamid
Sokka so with that you know my answer
was what was was come was completed now
I found a way of life that gave me a
world view it gave me a lifestyle how to
raise my family how to deal with my
children it gave me a dietary plan it
connected me with people of other races
other nationalities and so there I was
now in Canada you know looking at the
world all set and waiting for an opening
and you know by the mercy of Allah
Subhan Allah the creator of the heavens
and the earth the Saudi Arabian
government offered two scholarships to
Canada to the Canadian Muslim Canada
community in 1973 so I was one of the
two who was given the scholarship and I
went to Medina yes so as a young man
with my wife who I had married she was a
Muslim too and we went to Medina in 1973
now this was when Medina was in the old
form didn't have no tie roads we lived
in a simple house with no running water
my wife was originally from jamaica but
raised in canada so she knew how to live
a rough life so we lived with the
Bedouins and we learned classical Arabic
and it was Medina was beautiful and you
know it was the old Medina before the
hustle and bustle now that you find you
know with the skyscrapers and so in that
atmosphere we took in you know the
knowledge of islam alhamdulillah it was
a great struggle but I was the first
American to graduate from any university
in Saudi Arabia first American the first
American Marshall on our the first
American to graduate from that
prestigious university here in the Dean
show yeah mashallah so that was a great
achievement you know for me and from
there you know I became very close to a
very famous Chaka Chak abdulaziz bin
baths rahimahullah and he was a very
kind person he had memorized the whole
of bacardi hadith sayings of the Prophet
peace be
on him he was very kind and he wanted to
know about Islam in America so when I
graduated he said I want to meet this
person you know I want to talk to him
yeah so I SAT with him and you know he
befriended me and so he said I want you
to research America so he gave me an
open ticket to research Muslims in the
Americas it was a ticket like this size
and so I traveled literally throughout
the Caribbean i traveled to belize
honduras costa rica panama aruba guyana
Trinidad Jamaica Bermuda you know
Bahamas all throughout the region
investigating Muslim communities to give
an idea report about what is the state
of Islam in the in this region and from
there I went to California and taught
for a year and then I returned back to
Toronto and then I went into the
Caribbean and I lived in Jamaica for
four years so I taught and jamaica and
moved around the islands and spent some
beautiful years you know in the
Caribbean region returned to Toronto
where I was the imam of the big mosque
the jammy mosque from nineteen eighty
five to nineteen ninety and it is there
I my research blossomed because not only
why was I the imam of the mosque I
enrolled in the University at the same
time and I got a masters from the
University of Toronto and history
department and then I got a PhD from the
university of toronto and that was based
on the research i did in northern
nigeria so now i'm traveling the muslims
in nigeria invite me to a big conference
Islam in Africa because they wanted to
know about the roots of Muslims in the
Americas and they heard about my
research and writing so they invited me
there and so from there I met the
scholars of West Africa and you know I
brought back documents of a famous check
with Mandan folio a great scholar in the
nineteen 18th century there and I had 37
original documents in Arabic language
so I translated these documents
commented on them got a PhD and then I
began to travel around the world and so
I was I was invited to China Malaysia to
Europe to South America to Brazil to
many parts of the world to deliver
lectures about Islam in America and you
know a youth type of lectures and
because the globalization was happening
so people in the third world in the
Muslim world they want to know how could
we deal with our youth in this new
American onslaught this globalization
you know McDonald's is everywhere
kentucky fried chicken is everywhere how
do we handle this so now you know just
by the will of allah i happen to be in
the right place at the right time you
know I'm American and I'm you know
qualified in islamic studies i'm working
with the youth you know so i can provide
answers to them on the ground how to
deal with some of your problems your
family problems your youth problems and
so people invited me and so this is what
enabled me to travel you know so far
because it's not easy to travel in the
world you know with the prices of plane
tickets and whatnot so alhamdulillah i
was able to visit 58 countries you know
interacting with Muslims you know at the
same time researching any country i go
into I research I find the roots of the
people you know I asked them their
questions I record this information
right I document the information you
know and then I I put it in categories
and then I i get my worldview expands
you know so this enabled me you know to
to reach new heights in terms of
understanding Islam not only in America
but Islam in the world we're going to
take a break and we'll be right back
with more God willing on a TV show
go don't take the books put the books in
front of you and read them read the
Quran don't be afraid the question is
about whether Muslims are not good
citizens the Constitution defines what a
good citizen is and the preamble it says
we the people of the United States and
form a more perfect union establish
justice insure domestic tranquility
sunni muslim they can say that is a good
muslim and most Muslims can say that
most moves into embraces most persons
are good Americans
we're back with dr. Abdullah hakin quick
share thank you again for being with us
I'm very exciting now tell us before we
go on just a side note for the not yet
Muslims out there they're hearing Islam
how do you connect all of this the
prophets and then you got what is with
in their very nature we say worship the
One God and this is what from the
beginning of your story you didn't want
to worship the creation you didn't want
to worship a man you want to worship the
creator of all that exists but then they
hear this word Islam yeah they agree
with that so yeah I want to worship God
just god that's it not his creation but
how did islam they hear this Arabic term
they think well this is an Arab thing
and how do you respond to this well what
is important for us to understand is
that when we talk about Islam we are
talking about the root religion of all
of the prophets and the Quran itself
tells us in the chapter of the be that
prophets and messengers have been sent
to all nations and all tribes that they
should worship one God and stay away
from false deities so prophets came to
China to India to Europe to the Americas
every nation had a person who taught
them believe in one God and do not
worship the Sun or idols or worship
yourself but go beyond that and connect
to the universe and so that really you
know is what Islam is and when I
researched in the Arabic language you
know into them that the sayings of the
scholars I found out that that it is a
majority position amongst the scholars
that if a person has never heard
anything about Islam or Christianity or
Judaism no Moses Jesus Mohammed nobody
and that person believes in one God and
lives a good life then that person is
under the mercy of Allah he can be
punished or he can be forgiven and
basically that person is Muslim because
every human being is born in the natural
state of worshiping the Creator so there
are certain tribes now in the Amazon
valley of Amazon River they have met
nobody they don't know any profits they
don't know any organized form of
religion and these people as far as we
are concerned are Muslims until they are
proven the opposite
because they worship the Great Spirit
and this is found within their languages
I found the same thing on the African
continent every African language has a
concept of God I went into the British
Isles I went high up into scotland and i
found out that after the time of Jesus
peace be upon him that there was a
person who came in the area who taught
the people to believe in one God pure
monotheism pure monotheism how about
holy holy spirit father son Holy Ghost
this is before that that was the
organized Roman Church yet this had
nothing to do not teachings of the
Prophet so if you look around in Europe
itself you will find pure monotheistic
teachings just one guy unitarians and
the original so nothing to do with any
mixing garden to you know these are
three and one of these no these are the
original Unitarians in Europe itself it
was the organized Roman Church the
Trinitarians you know who forced you
know this what we were considered to be
a pagan belief of the many gods from
Greece and Rome basis you know they
force that on you know the native people
in Europe itself as well as other parts
of the world and so it's interesting for
me in Chinese the Chinese say Shang t
Shang tea and Shang T is the one got one
guy that's the creator of the help stop
there you don't add anything app just
one right so that's that's the the
cosmic spirits can you see him you going
to church and you see a black God that
Jesus is black with blue eyes over here
he's hey Zeus you know brown not white
no image to god no no area code zip code
no DNA that's right none of that and the
same thing in Africa I found there's a
nation call the ban tues and the band to
is from the word n 2 and n 2 is the
cosmic spirit that's the Creator so the
band two are the children of God the
children of the cosmic spirit you know
of the creator of the heavens and the
earth and so you'll find in every
African language a way to express one
God you'll find even in the ancient
vitas of India the original Sanskrit
writings you were not supposed to
worship idols yeah you will look at
Buddha himself he left the idols he is
looking for the one
God yeah so if you go behind the great
religions of the world was his name his
name was Buddha Buddha yeah okay he was
going out looking for though he was a
prince and Hindu prints and he didn't
want to worship idols anymore he was
tired of living this life so he left his
riches he left idol worship in search of
the Great Spirit yeah unfortunately now
he's his image is the biggest idol in
the world people are like look at him
giving him divine rights yeah but that's
people that's not Buddha himself same
thing with can you connect it with Jesus
did the same as I call people to worship
himself never and it is recorded that
Jesus peace be upon him was a very
humble person you know who walked most
of the time without shoes on very simple
and very loving and he followed the law
of Moses completely and and and that has
nothing to do with any Trinity concept
or other gods but it is it is a pure
belief in Yahweh in the creator of the
heavens and the earth and that was his
belief and so you'll find this in the
root religions and in the indigenous
people of all nations including Europe
you will find this toe heat and that is
the unity and so this is what I have
found over the years traveling to
different parts of the world studying
history studying history studying
culture studying people that really
behind the the so-called differences
within people you know there is a human
spirit there is a soul there is a
connection with the Creator which is
common amongst all people now tell us
someone might fall out their seat right
now and this is something that might
come as a shock but is this what I'm
saying the truth a we love Jesus peace
be upon him and Jesus was a Muslim is
this true that's right because I mean
what I found from after I left the
church is that when I entered into Islam
it really gave me the true story of
Jesus the true story of Mary and so my
love for Jesus increased my love for
Mary increased peace be upon them but I
now ask was connected to the actual
story in the way it happened because
jesus never
wanted people to worship him he always
pointed to the Father meaning the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
so we understand what the word father
means in somatic languages is not your
physical father we're all children of
God so it is the creator of the heavens
and the earth this is like metaphorical
then exactly so this is really what he
was pointing to now you know you know
speaking Arabic which is the sister
language of Hebrew you say Shalom
Aleichem and we say assalamo alaikum so
it's did their sister languages now I
was in touch with revelation yeah and so
I could go straight to the book I could
listen to you know to the words of the
Prophet Muhammad SAW seldom in the
original language itself I lived in the
city so now I realize this is not a
ritualistic religion this is not Arabs
and non-arabs this is the religion of
all people this is all racists so he was
by definition a Muslim because what is a
Muslim other than what you're describing
one who is just connecting with the one
guy exactly so this is the root
definition now that one who submits to
do the will of Allah or God this is a
Muslim so that's what Moses did Abraham
Noah Jesus Christ peace be upon him all
they did that so they were Muslim that's
right amazing and we also found out that
there are people like in ancient Egypt
Akhenaten whose wife was Nefertiti many
people know Nefertiti that Naughton you
know challenged to the gods of Egypt and
in some reports he was not worshipping
the Sun God he wanted the worship the
power behind the Sun and he challenged
Egypt just before the time of Moses and
so you will find that there dis dis dis
you know these teachings amongst the
Cherokee Nation sequoia there's a famous
teacher in amongst the Cherokee he was
the first person amongst the Cherokee
Nation in America to institute an
alphabet he created the alphabet of the
Cherokee if you look at a picture of
Sequoia he's got a turban on like mine
and he's got a soap and you read the
Cherokee writings and you will find a
strong belief in one God that they are
looking to the east you know and that
they are believers the Seminole nation
in Florida you will find Seminoles
a mixture of many people who fled from
the Spanish you know settlers you know
and that the natives they ran together
and they form this nation if you look at
pictures of the Seminoles they have
turbines on like Mayan and they have
dopes and some of them have even names
with Arabic in it so so really Islam was
here in America as well not only from
the root religion of the First Nation
indigenous people but Muslims who had
come across as well here in America here
in America and that's a that's a
research that I did in my book called
deeper roots you know where we found
present roots is the book you wrote on
this right deeper roots to show presence
of Muslims in America before Columbus
before Columbus that's right you got
approved for this proof of it somehow
and then how they actually mixed with
the native people in the Americas long
before the 13 colonies were developed
Muslims in America Islam in America way
before Christopher Columbus that's right
and you're hearing it here on the Dean
show be right back emphasizing and
ascertaining the oneness of God
recognizing that there is a creator and
that Creator has given us the blueprints
as you have don't take anything for
granted don't just follow anything
blindly anything you believe research it
really understand what it is you're
believing and questioning things and
question them and search usually and
honestly
back here with dr. Abdullah Hakim quick
here on the Dean show talking about how
he came to Islam and his wonderful
experiences from going to being a
Christian a young man who was inspiring
to learn the truth and then coming to
the truth and that now inspiring to
great heights you an Islamic scholar a
historian one who's really embedded
engrossed and seeking knowledge tell us
now someone comes and says you know what
okay yeah I believe in God God and you
got in me God's everywhere it's all good
we're all God's how would you just
decide know how would you tackle this
question and have you come across this
yes I mean one time I was you know
having an interaction with people you
know about Islam and a tough guy come to
me and he said I'm God and he and he
went right up in my face okay now I have
a background from the streets right so I
mean you know I'm a nice Muslim preacher
so he come up to me and he said I'm god
I said okay God put your hand in front
of your face so he put his hand in front
of his face at home right now right put
your hand and I put my fingers in back
of his hand yeah and I said count how
many fingers I have of course he
couldn't see it just like I said okay
you're God man and you can't see right
there uh-huh what kind of God are you
yeah so he just put his head down and
walked away because what I was trying to
show him is that when you say God you
are talking about one who is divine in
all qualities you're talking about the
one who sees all things and knows all
things and here's all things and you
know above seven heavens it's not me and
you we're earthly people we have
problems man obviously you can you not
see in all things you can't you can't
even see in front of his face so what
kind of a god is he right yeah you know
so I mean that's how you have to deal
with some p silly stuff you know and
people have to you know realize that
that revelation that prophecy you know
that god this is a very serious thing
because we're connected to the Hereafter
yeah we're not only in this world we're
on a journey and shortly we'll be
leaving this world so what will be the
condition of our soul where will we go
so we need to really you know search
this and really you know you know come
to grips with with our frail existence
and prepare ourselves for the next life
definitely definitely and this is what
all the messages are God taught didn't
they that's right so tell us now a few
more points we want
get them in another person is loving
what you have to say but you're like you
know what I'm just I believe in God but
I'll do my own thing I don't want to
really follow an organized religion I do
believe in the one guy but I just I'm
comfortable doing my own thing well I
guess well you know it's the same as a
person who's a pretty good mechanic you
know and then we bring him a new
Lamborghini and this Lamborghini needs
to be put together so he's a mechanic he
has a pretty good idea of cars so he'll
try to put it together and he'll stay in
well this is a new vehicle but now I can
bring you the instruction manual for the
Lamborghini you know made by the company
who developed the car okay so similarly
with the human being revelation you know
it's not saying we don't have
intelligence but this is the creator of
the human being who knows better why we
are created how we are created so he's
giving us a lifestyle in order like a
manual in order that we can you know run
our machine in the proper way so in the
same way that that mechanic who uses you
know the manual for the Lamborghini he
will be successful he will have his car
runnin with the other guy you know he
might do okay but he'll never reach the
speed he'll never make the ultimate
success of the one who follows the
manual so we say the final Testament and
the final manual that is the Quran and
we should be reading this Quran every
human being you should know what it is
you should read it and you should
investigate the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him his lifestyle his teachings
because this is the way that we will be
led from this confusion of the world we
are living in into the openness and
purity of the hereafter tell us shake
just a couple more points tell us now so
many wonderful things when people are
sincere humble hearted open-minded they
look and they see you know Islam is a
way of life of peace peace with the
Creator peace with yourself in the peace
with the rest of society but now okay
they want to go with what's in their
very nature to worship the One God and
do all the good things as he's told us
to do but they always hear from the
media Islam being associated with
terrorism
things blowing up and now they're little
timid their little nervous they're
sincere but you're like I don't I don't
want to be called a terrorist what you
guys say what is important to understand
is that time we need to look beyond
terminologies because if you look at the
the American colonies if you look at
America when it was first founded the
people who declared independence when
the Constitution was first developed
they were called terrorists and the
British were intent upon destroying you
know that the leadership of America and
ruining this in this country but even
though they were called terrorists they
continued on because of the principles
that they were founding so similarly you
know with Muslims yes we do have
extremists in the Muslim world like any
other nation there are extremists
amongst Christians Jews communists
atheists every grouping has extremists
but but the faith itself you look at the
principles you know and that's really
you know where we stand on and you know
my experience was not originally it's
not a political one it first benefits me
as a person so look at Islam for
yourself your connection with the
Creator your family your diet the way
that you function in this world your
instant your worldview and then you can
start to expand you know to the other
areas and when we get into the you know
the realm of the world we will see that
it's not politics in the world as poly
tricks that really there's a lot of
tricking going on in confusion in the
world and and sometimes we have to sort
of get away from that and go back to
basics yes you know to the baixas basics
of ourselves as human beings you know
Anna in our connection with God because
we are shortly leaving this world and
that really is what Islam you know can
give you know to the individual and we
can only pray that the world will find
some way to develop piece that all
nations can live together and people can
find a way of using the technology not
to destroy but to save the planet one
more on this one more this is important
point we've done programs on this and
we've condemned we've got other scholars
who have condemned this but seems like
people keep throwing his back and they
keep revisiting this and they keep
throwing those out
guys 911 Islam and Muslims and now
creating the sensationalism what do we
have to say about this if they come up
to you and they feel this in your face
how do we use man well you know we have
to look at events in the world for what
is happening on the ground I've been
living in South Africa for the past 10
years and the former president nelson
mandela at one point he was called the
terrorist yeah because he was
terrorizing the apartheid government and
but once people realize what was
happening and and he was able to have
the patience you know and the resistance
you know to come out of the prison you
and then take over the country he moved
from being a terrorist to a world leader
to a Nobel Peace Prize winner ok so
these names are thrown you know back and
forth and you know there's a lot of
things going on in the world but the
reality is that we need to look at
affairs from all points of view you
cannot judge an issue from one side
that's the reason why I study the roots
of history you know not as we called it
we used to say history was his story
yeah so we look at it from not his story
but our story the story of humanity so
if a person really wants to know about
Islam then you know and Muslims they
should go to Muslims you know and read
about Islam yeah instead of just reading
you know another source in the
newspapers they should go you know take
it from the horse's mouth as you say go
right to the source so Islam has nothing
to do with killing innocent women
children nothing whatsoever exactly it's
very clear and the teachings of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him that
even when he sent his soldiers out in
defense of the nation he told him do not
kill innocents to not kill
non-combatants he said even said do not
destroy churches and synagogues do not
kill monks and and rabbis you know do
not destroy infrastructure meaning don't
poison the water don't destroy trees
keep everything intact because we are
not there to destroy we're only
defending ourselves we're only
establishing justice and if the enemy
asked for peace give it to them
immediately that is what is because
Islam is based on peace
so it's a total distortion about what
Muslims are we don't say assalamu
alaykum means peace be upon you it
doesn't mean bomb be upon you it's peace
be upon these and this is what we're
saying all the time and people have to
realize this when they're dealing with
Muslims last closing comments and
suggestions for the truth seekers those
now because there were also those who
were vengeance against Islam vilifying
Islam even at the time of the last
fundamental card Muhammad peace be upon
it but somehow they ended up coming to
Islam so even those people and the
sincere people talk to them or give them
some good advice to soften their heart
and maybe God willing even to have them
come to the true of live on the truth
and dying the truth well they need to
remember that the times we are living in
now its turbulent times and with the
change going on in the environment the
world that we know will never be the
same the floods that are hitting the
world the earthquakes the famines
diseases they are now being described as
the worst calamities in living memory
the oil spill you know on the east coast
of the United States and we all need to
pray you know for some solution to this
this will be the worst disaster in our
memory and this is the age that we are
going into now so we need to drop these
you know false you know superficial
titles and names and come together as a
human family and try to find ways that
we connect with each other as opposed to
finding divisions between each other
come together as a human family deal
with the environment deal with nature
the animals are crying out the burden
that birds are dying the fish are dying
insects are being destroyed this world
were all interconnected this is what
they call biodiversity we're part of a
grand plan and we need to take our role
you know as the representatives of God
on this earth and come together as a
human family and you will see when you
really touch Muslims you will find that
Muslims have a great role to play in
this world and in the future of this
planet
thank you thank you shave for being with
us may god almighty the crater that
happens on earth Allah reward you so
thank you and let us come to a common
terms between us and you that we worship
none but the one God the creator of all
that exists the creator of Moses Abraham
Jesus the crater of the Sun and the moon
the creator of everything that is in
existence that one God and that's
something that's in your very nature you
just got to let it out don't suppress it
and you see and you've heard it here on
a Dean show where people of peace first
we have peace with the owner of peace
the creator of the heavens and earth he
gives us peace and then we wish you
peace assalamualaikum and we'll see you
next time here on the Dean show until
then again peace be unto you